sunday is going to be bonkers here in
vegas you obviously got that much
anticipated opener and then the first
ever aces finals home game as well mark
davis is going to need two screens going
kevin martin kevin martin is on our
screen to talk game one
like becky says we don't tiptoe into a
bar fight they're like they're they are
the bar fight like it's just gonna be
war
it's down to just two teams the aces and
the sun
with the wnba title on the line it's
going to be exciting it's going to be
exciting i mean feel like it's the
finals now so we're going to put
everything out there
they got to guard us we got to guard
them so it's going to be in a very
exciting series vegas has been in this
position before back in 2020 but this
time around the more experienced aces
are expecting a much different outcome i
think in the bubble we it was we were
kind of just like oh we're just happy to
be here this is our first time a lot of
people had us not even making it that
far so it's kind of like okay like we
got an opportunity
but i think this time it's kind of like
we deserve to be here we've earned we
fought our way here we understand what
it means to be here that fight and
mental fortitude was on full display in
the semifinals with all four games
against seattle going down to the wire
preparing vegas for what's likely to
come in this best of five finals matchup
i mean if there's anything that we've
learned
throughout these playoffs is that every
second and every moment matters and you
have to be present for all of it there's
no time to panic run our stuff do handle
what we can handle take care and be in
control we can be in control of the aces
have pretty much checked everything off
the list this season as far as personal
and team accolades except for one thing
and they are just three wins away from
not only claiming the first championship
in franchise history but giving las
vegas its first major professional
sports title
ever we meant it at the beginning we
said we want to win a championship like
this hasn't been done here and so we're
we're really like that's on the
forefront of our minds kevin martin 8
sports now